I was very turned on by this woman I
ended up hooking up with her several
times without the guy really that I was
dating yes that's what I knew it was
time to break up with the guys
she was your masseuse and then you were
more into her than yeah him Chelsea
Handler is not holding back the dirty
details from her past relationships
nobody has rules for Comics anyway the
comedian opening up to Andy Cohen about
her dating life on his Sirius XM show
have you dated a woman I've slept with a
woman but I haven't dated a woman no
yeah and that led to these curious
follow-up questions from the Bravo host
was it a one-off or was it was like a
threesome oh really yeah yeah and how
did that go for you fun I mean it was
fun did you ever do that again I would
for sure you would do that again yeah
did you do it to please the man you were
dating him no I was very turned on by
this woman I ended up hooking up with
her several times without the guy really
that I was dating yes oh that's what I
knew it was time to break up with the
guy that guy was
Ted Harbor and turns out he never knew
about the affair I mean hopefully he's
listening now his name is Ted Harbor
Portugal though so he might not have
access so you give
Harbert a threesome for maybe like a
special occasion yeah and then she was
your masseuse and then you were more
into her than yeah him kind of well yes
you two dated for a while four years
four years yeah I like when it's
interesting and so um as long as I can
keep myself interested we're in good
shape seems as of now Chelsea's enjoying
the single life following her split from
Bellow comedian Joe Coy last June the
relationship didn't work out we both
went our separate ways you know I had
kind of lost my faith in men and you
know I then I got into a relationship
and I that that Faith was renewed and it
made me open-minded and open-hearted and
I remain that way and so I'm grateful
for that time together and as far as any
future threesomes go it's definitely
something Chelsea's not opposed to would
you ever in a relationship gift your man
a three-way absolutely it's fun
foreign